cool there you are i found you i mean
not found you cause it's not like i was
looking for you or anything but here we
are wanna pirate you
bet your booty i wanna wait hold that
thought
two pairs of fresh young eyes they can
help me find the key okay helen
keep it keep it low-key keep it low-key
track it back back track keep it low-key
ask the kid what you did where the dog
peed just keep it keep it low-key keep
it low-key you want to help me out i
think i lost a key
no i dropped it on our walk which may
have been your last cause if i lost the
key then betsy will replace me with some
super stringent
new assistant who won't be chill as me
they won't let you walk the shih tzu so
will you help me find the keys
[Music]
he like spanish maybe could be on the
ground i know we're not allowed but in
emergencies we need your expertise with
the metal detector
don't object her you will break my heart
you can trust me daddy won't see so will
you help us find a kissy
[Music]
keep it low-key
[Music]
nothing okie dokie
[Music]
just keep it keep it low-key keep it
low-key just keep it keep it low-key